pop over the sierra box you got beat up
too by the way really oh they beat him
up
did you see that one journalist who
keeps getting beat up and then keeps
saying thank you antifa please may have
another
i i haven't seen that one but so i'm i'm
i'm being rude but there's this uh
like andy knows tweeted about him he got
beat up the first time okay
and then andy no was like auntie fuzz
put a bounty on this guy's head
and so then the dude tweets the feds
it's it's actually
you know it's not not antifa the feds
are trying to stop me you know they're
they're they're committing war
crimes then they beat him up again and
he posts a video
saying something like yeah they beat me
up but it's okay like i'll be all right
you know i'm more concerned with the
police
it's like dude how many times are you
gonna get beat up and then you're going
to
act like how many times you have to
teach this same lesson
right yeah so take a look at this
article from vox
portland polarization and the crisis of
the republican party
wow what that to me man
is um it is now officially political
well it's not confidence-building yeah
quote we are witnessing a crisis of
democracy that is perfectly acceptable
to a significant portion of the
population as long as it hurts their
enemies
okay i don't want anyone hurt okay what
are they thinking
i really the old saying bro they really
want everyone to believe
that there's this huge mass of people
that are racist
that that want death upon their enemies
it's like no we want america to stop
fighting and we want to work together
period that's what everyone wants they
want this this silliness to stop
most people are looking at these people
like they're just spoiled little brats
including myself and there are a lot of
sick of it that are too stupid
to know what's going on and just see
this and think it must be true
right like you know what it's the old
saying that uh repub
republicans think that democrats are
misguided democrats think republicans
are evil
right exactly so i i think at the
highest level like
vox i believe the people who run it i
believe they're evil i do
and the reason i say that and i use
these words i use like evil very
carefully
is because the people who are funding
this know exactly what they're funding
they're conscious of it
so a lot of people talk about like
grifting on social media
and they say you know tim's just
choosing these stories because they get
the most clicks and stuff like that and
it's like actually i choose the stories
that i think are the most interesting
and important
right exactly like today i talked about
ufos because that pentagon thing and i'm
pretty sure it's not going to do as well
as me talking like i could have recorded
a segment on this
yeah instead i was like i got to talk
about ufos man this is this is fun and
crazy i gotta
there's nothing nothing concrete yet for
me of course of course but anyway the
point is
vox cnn buzzfeed these are companies
where in the morning
the boss comes in and says who's gonna
give me that story that gets a million
clicks
i'll buy a pizza and then they're like i
got this story about joe biden
saying that he wants to defund the
police nah no one cares about that you
got something on trump
i got one of trump that we can take out
of context where it sounds like he wants
to like beat a dog to death
oh that's good how many hits you think
that will get two million
run it the thing about a corporation
that does this
is that people have to consciously say
what is the story and which one will do
better run with that one i've been in
these meetings i've heard them
where they've pitched things now it's
not that insane they'll be like yo i
heard this story about you know this guy
on a hacking website who got like his
name released and
not interesting enough what about you um
i think donald trump is racist
that one do that one the people in
charge know
what they're choosing and why they're
choosing it it's very different from an
individual being like
here's my opinion on these issues and
here's what i think matters
the company is like here's our broadly
defined or like a you know narrowly
defined
you know uh story purview if you look at
some of these
earlier companies like mike.com
was was like libertarian until they
realized social justice
the police brutality stuff it made them
more money
this is what i've been told so i'll just
tell you that it's like you know
scuttlebutt
but then all of a sudden became a
leftist social justice company because
they were chasing the money
the the owners were actively pursuing
this the scary thing about this article
from vox
is i think they're right when they say
we are witnessing a crisis of democracy
that is true it is
that it is uh that is perfectly
acceptable to a significant portion of
the population
yes and it hurts their enemies i believe
that of the far left and the democrats
so it's the the faulty statement there
would be the republican party it's more
the democrat party and i can prove it
with one simple bit of logic
go for it the republicans aren't showing
up to the homes of politicians the
republicans aren't showing up to
courthouse buildings
and and vandalizing and destroying them
and in this context
federal police are not going to the
homes of antifa to beat and detain them
yeah we're not talking about creedy's
little black bags showing up to
comedian's house bashing in the face and
throwing them in a van
we're talking about far leftists trying
to burn down a building
assaulting police officers assaulting
journalists they assaulted journalist
michael tracy did you see that video
they stole his phone from him and say if
you want it back say black lives matter
oh that one right
and then you want to tell me that
there's a group of people that are okay
with this when i try talking to my
friend saying hey they're assaulting
journalists
so what don't you know what's going on
why won't you talk about police
brutality
and i'm like because uh they're beating
up a journalist in the street
right now right now yeah and i messaged
you about place brutality when it
happened last week
can you no and then they just shut down
no or how about how about all the kids
that are being killed across this
country
yup they're not talking about that and
how they're lying
conflating diligent valor with with
operation legend
yeah they're they're definitely mixing
those up that's that to me is
is the is the creepiest stuff i want to
show you one more thing with this this
is just some article it's an
investigative post i don't know what
this is
but it's very simple the state police
have troopers trained in emergency
response that's the only sentence you
need to hear
so if state security forces show up
and say this is an unlawful assembly you
must disperse they use the already and
they fire tear gas
yeah you can you can complain about it
if if they're you know pushing the
boundary and violating your rights you
can complain about it you can file suit
but to act like it's the end of the
world and that trump is the the you know
the dictator it's it's it's insane how
fake all this is
yeah they literally just make all this
stuff up i mean one can argue that
uh i mean there's i know the defamation
laws you know the libel laws
it's their they're directly causing
people to
believe that there is a war going on
within our country
so you can almost you can almost say
that these faulty
you know media posts are leading people
to
cause violence and actually damage
damaged communities it's like
there's a direct correlation to their bs
and what's actually happening out there
you know i was really disappointed they
got to be held liable for that
there's a reporter named josh rushing he
works for al jazeera's fault lines or i
think he may have you
he used to okay and i used to uh i still
respect him
and i i say this because i it bums me
out he did this bit
where he has someone film him while he
calls tucker carlson on speakerphone
and tucker he's like tucker you recently
said that white supremacy was a hoax and
there are people in el paso that feel
like your rhetoric is inflaming things
makes them targeted tucker's response
was hey why don't you send the questions
to uh the media people because you know
i'm not i'm not supposed
to you know do this and then they made a
bit out of it
and it is the lowest form of trash
content and i was surprised that this
dude
who um i guess he had he had served in
the military
uh maybe a marine i'm not entirely sure
okay and then he became like a a host
for an
al jazeera show called fault lines and
i'm like this is what it's come to now
man
like you're gonna go from reporting in
in conflict zones
to being the guy in the street gotcha in
tucker carlson because someone gave you
a cell phone number
yeah that's what it's become that's
that's media today
and i was just like and now now what
he's doing is he's re he's like
reposting it again a year later like hey
everybody look what i did
well in not all media huh
yeah all right sorry we need
we need to figure how um figure out how
to fix it how to hold them liable for
lying blatantly to the american public
yeah i agree
you know you don't definitely need to
figure that out it's very difficult
these companies like vox and bloomberg
have
institutional power in the sense that
they use their collective view
viewership
to empower people who are really really
dumb and lie
so you get these journalists who
normally would have no influence because
they're talentless
and they're liars but they're placed up
on a pedestal with tens of
or hundreds of millions of dollars by
major corporations that push their
message out so you get these you know
i think it's one of the reasons why they
really want to control social media
because social media became a
open space for meritocracy where someone
like
me for instance could just start making
content and with zero marketing budget
gain a ton of followers and get millions
of views
they don't want that they want the
machine to control it yeah
so now they're like ban it all shut it
all down but i'll tell you what man it's
it's hard some days when i see vox
you know i i probably saw like 30
stories all saying the same
fake thing unidentified police
yeah where a judge just ruled they're
clearly identifiable in the videos you
showed me what is this
yeah there's there's a few friends of
mine that are arguing
that like you know how how can you
defend this operation legend that
when look at what's happening in
portland of course they live in portland
right and they're like i'm i go outside
everything's fine nothing's like that
like how can you say that and it's just
like
you live there and you're telling me
that the videos that i'm watching
of the actual courthouse being attacked
and then here we have a court order so
the judge
issuing like nope that's they're they're
well within their rights to do what
they're doing
telling me like no it's it's terrible
that that you believe that that think
that you're the issue like you're
believing
the false lies so they truly believe
what the truth is is the lie think about
how psychotic it is right now that cnn
and oregonian and all of these outlets
are arguing that portland is fine
right they're like there's nothing
really going on in portland it's not
burning down nothing's happening
and then they turn around and go trump's
gestapo they're snatching people off the
streets it's chaos in bedlam
and then which is it which is it is it
trump's secret police
renditioning people or is it
everything's fine nothing's really
happening i haven't noticed anything
if you're gonna go if you live in
portland and you're like everything's
fine then why would you complain about
operation legend oh then great then you
wouldn't care if the fbi shows up to
chicago
right because everything's fine amid
donald trump's diligent valor i believe
it's
chiraq right now yeah yeah is the uh
appropriate label it's that simple
if you think the the the dhs people in
portland is not a big deal because
portland is fine
then why would i believe you when you
say how dare trump send federal agents
to a different city
why your city's fine and then we got the
press secretary doing a uh
you know you know a speech to everybody
and
showing a video of what's actually yeah
fox well
they were covering it and uh of course
she shows video of the actual
riots the actual fire the actual you
know mortars being shot at the
courthouse
and the the you know the statues being
toppled sure there was a there was some
graffiti there
that people are claiming well there was
graffiti that was you know
said a swear word so they they were
going to get fined and it's like no
that's not what they wanted they didn't
want the general public to see what was
going on in portland
period that's what it was i mean if you
truly
and and people are just bombarding any
any twitter feed that i see
about that it's just all these people on
the left like no no it was just a swear
word don't worry they just took down
from the swear word it's like no that's
not what it was
they don't want anyone knowing about the
actual goings of portland right now
they want them to believe that
everything's fine important they want
you to join the borg
yep exactly they want you to be a part
of the hive there's no war
there yeah there is no war in boston you
will be assimilated
resistance is futile this is what they
want they want you
they they they're they're reactionaries
yeah right so
um for those who aren't familiar with
the phrase and a lot of people aren't
that's why i'll define it
reactionary is a reference to i believe
the uh french revolution
where the left wing and that's where
left and right comes from
the jacobins in the left and and the
revolutionary types
called the right that wanted to support
the monarchy reactionaries who reacted
to the revolution
yeah so today the left is really good at
using they're they're
they're they understand the power of
semantics and how words shape reality
that's why they change definitions of
words and that's why
they will call like they'll call liberal
individuals like freedom loving
individuals libertarian individuals
conservatives
reactionaries to imply that you
in fact are resisting the true progress
when in reality
the left is trying to rewind the clock
on everything our understanding of
freedom of speech which was earned in
supreme court battles throughout the 60s
remember that you ever see that great
berkeley banner where they march on
berkeley free speech
our modern understanding of free speech
was solidified in supreme court rulings
it wasn't always this way we had
obscenity laws we had a ton of stuff
that restricted us from speaking so then
you get it's just it's it's
it's too tiring sometimes man i believe
it they
they change the definitions of words
they call you the reactionary
they call you the fascist but what these
people are doing
repealing civil rights law that's insane
that's reactionary
okay what happened was we had an
ideological revolution that all people
are created equal and we fought very
hard for this
if you it's very simple if you want to
repeal a law to go back
to the way things were you're a
reactionary
they call everyone else fascist why
because they
actually use those fascist tactics
so they call themselves the the not
fascists club
and then when they start doing fascist
things they're like
we're the not fascists you [ __ ] we
can't possibly do fascism
now they're not necessarily doing
fascism but they've cleverly disguised
their reactionary views which is
fascistic
for progressivism think about how how
very like clever it is to say
we oppose racism therefore we must
repeal civil rights law
i it boggles my mind people believe it
i know i and they're actually out there
defending it it's like
how can you defend that they they
think that it it's so virtuous like oh
man
but we're going to get true diversity
they don't they don't think it's i don't
think so i think
in their in their head dude they're
thinking that maybe
maybe like the the the grunts and the
peons yeah the people who truly believe
it's a good thing
they think it's a good thing you know
they think it's a virtue
and this is this is you can easily
verify
like the way i see this is very i
believe it's logically
i believe i'm correct and it's very
simple first one of the tactics
they call the proposition to repeal
civil rights the affirmative action
amendment
right and all it does is repeal civil
rights yeah
that's that's incredible the democrats
realized
that they were like wait a minute all
the racist things that were really hard
to get done
i know democrats decided they'll pretend
not to be racist
and then they can start doing all the
racist things and no one will stop them
it works
and then label this this bill that we're
going to push forward as the
affirmative action bill when literally
it just strikes civil rights law yep
exactly they're reactionaries that want
to turn back the clock on our freedoms
our civil rights
while arguing it's you that wants to do
it let me tell you something
when someone on the right a libertarian
a moderate politically homeless idw
says individuals deserve freedom no
matter what their race color creed
national origin
that is progress that is us recognizing
the fundamental human rights
the unalienable rights of every person
that was originally enshrined in the
constitution
and we fully realized over the next 100
200 years
they're trying to literally repeal those
laws
to take it back to a simpler time
because they're racists
right so so all those all those crazy
democrat leftists that were yelling at
trump when he was like make america
great again when reagan said it clinton
said it
bill clinton said it for hillary clinton
in 2008 too that blew me away i was like
wow that wasn't even that long ago and
now they're like oh what what time do
you want to go back to and it's like
when our infrastructure was was solid
yeah
when pipes in in flint michigan were
were good
you know it's like there's there's a
graphic that i see a bunch of lefties
share
it's from robert reich i think his name
is and it shows like the great
prosperity of like 1947 to 1979
and it's like every class in the country
was skyrocketing and wealth yeah that's
a good era actually
and then from 1980 till now only the top
one percent has grown while the middle
class has been stagnant
so when donald trump so i see everyone
sharing this like
what happened how come we were all doing
so you know every class was doing so
well and something changed in 1980
and now only the one percent is
prospering so you're saying you want to
make america great again
you want to go back to the old days yes
1940s
when the economy was was bolstering is
that what you're saying 1950s
1950s 60s what happened in the 60s
welfare was created also i we've had
this conversation so i know where you're
leading into this no no no
i mean i wasn't oh you want to talk
about it though well
what i was going to say is there's
there's a lot of factors okay that
resulted in the middle class stagnation
i mean immigration is one
um feminism is one welfare is one
but the point i'm bringing up is when
donald when donald trump says
make america great again and they say
when was america great
i bring you back to all the leftists who
said remember when we had a 90
tax rate maybe trump meant that oh you
don't think he did i don't either
the point is biden's trying to bring
back higher taxes yeah that's true
no the point is there's a lot of there
was a lot of things that the left claims
were better back way back when
and if trump says he wants to make
america great again then why don't you
just be like oh
uh that thing you talked about the tax
bracket yeah that's when america was
great how about that thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you